we didn't do anything wrong and anis
just decimated us now
it was April the 11th when the first
member of Chris's family passed away it
was his 84 year old mother-in-law Joan
who lived with the couple and had spent
time on a Cove in nineteen ward
following an operation Chris went to
tell his wife upstairs who was herself
suffering with symptoms of the virus i
just opened the bedroom door I said do
your mother's call that was it I
couldn't go in and hug her at all I just
had to leave it all alone
basically just four days later Julian's
condition worsened I said you want
anything it was about 10 to 12 and a
midnight and she'd all can you can you
run me a bath so I I run in a bath I
went back in those I was talking to her
and she she turned around and she said
to me can you she said I think I need to
go in and as soon as she said that I
grabbed my phone I dialed 999
but it's family press ENTER and turned
around to her she'd slumped back on a
bed and she was far away no I knew she
was gone Chris gave CPR before
paramedics arrived
but 45 minutes later she'd passed Chris
I can't imagine how difficult this was
how did you tell your son that his
mother had died he come down obviously
they'd already have to tell him on
Sunday that his nanny had died I said
Everton he said yeah I said them a mum
he's gone to be with Nami and Holly I'm
done he said why I said she's gone with
nanny mate and he just gave over give
you a hug he has a little cry in the
afternoon he said then he said who's
next that he is it gonna be you or is it
gonna be me I said I hope is none of us
I said we don't want anymore to be he
said no Chris himself spent a week in
hospital with Kovac 19 but has now
recovered as the lockdown continues
he has this message for those not
sticking to it you got these people
still going out now and you think just
just please going it's not just for you
is for me why are you out this is
unbelievable
just just stay in the house it's not
worth it like these two shot Dan
Whitehead Sky News